اذا كما شاهدنا مشاهدينا نتابع وصول
الانسه طبعا رجوى السيفيه سعوديه ولكن
يمكننا هنا الاشاره الى العلاقات
الاجتماعيه وروابط النسب والمظاهره التي
تجمع بين العائلات السعوديه والاردنيه
اخرها طبعا في هذا الزواج وعقد القران من
ولي العهد الاردني الامير الحسين بن عبد
الله الثاني من الانسه السعوديه رجوى
السيف ايضا كان هناك بالفين 2006 عقد
للامير هاشم بن الحسين عقد الاقرانه على
السيده السعوديه فهدى ابو نيان وتحديدا في
السادس من يناير 2006 وايضا ارتبطت
الاميره نور بنت عاصم وهي حفيده الملك عبد
الله الاول ملك المملكه الاردنيه من رجل
الاعمال والفارس السعودي عمرو زيدان في
ال22 من يونيو 2018 اذن هناك امتداد
عشائري روابط اسريه تجمع شعبي السعوديه
والاردن حيث يتش ارك البلدان العادات
وايضا التقاليد الاجتماعيه بما في ذلك
التراث والثقافه وايضا الاهازيج الشعبيه
والاطباق الغذائيه
طبعا من يزف العروس
الان
وايضا الثاني طبعا
وشقيقتيه في الخلف
[موسيقى]
اذا الانسه رجوى في طريقها الان الى
القاعه الرئيسيه طبعا في قصر الزهران حيث
سيعقد
قرانها على الامير الحسين الذي يتواجد
وشاهدنا صوره كان قبل ذلك
العهد الاردني والملكه رانيا في استقبال
الحضور ضيوف حفل الزفاف
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات